ni moi ni aucun regard dans ma poche
j'ai un object et très très familier
c'est parce que c'est donc tu vas mettre
la main par dessus et on verra on verra
à la fin
ce qu'on va faire avec la capote sanguin
il s'appelle regard gfr 70 cartes comme
ça et tu vas me dire stop quand que la
wii et vas-y tu prends la carte tu les
regardes tu la montre à tout le monde
sauf à moi je parle avec arme avec un
super c'est bon mais n'hésite falloir
mettre dans le jeu bravo ok maintenant
c'est rien ça fait faire passer des
cartes comme ça une équipe va me dire
stop quand tu veux saisir
stop la mac tu vas prendre la carte je
peux l'avoir celle là c'est bon d'accord
donc 4 de 84,2 car au hockey tu vas te
mettre comme ça il fait prendre en photo
avec faire un grand sourire parfait si
isabelle c'était quoi ta carte
je peux le dire vas-y tu petit de
carreaux à ce gars au hockey regarde je
prends le 9 de carreau
je plie en quatre et je l'envoie vers
jean michel maintenant est ce que tu
peux ouvrir la capote s'il te plaît
vas-y tu as l'habitude l'instant non
et tout cela fait trop c'est trop
imagine que sur ceux peppers bord byetta
photo qui apparaissent n'y en a pas
c'est incroyable avec une carotte c'est
impossible d'être ou regarde ça qui fait
eau